I was getting ready to Sue this guy
because he literally tried to destroy my
character my reputations a lot of stuff
it's about two months into it I set back
and I started feeling sorry for this guy
I was gonna pull the trigger sue him and
I said I'm not gonna Sue this guy for
you to be this person you are in a very
very bad place come to find out he was
in a very bad mental place I think if
you got to see the inner texture of the
people who don't like use existence
you'd feel more pity than anger I have
pity in a lot of people I've learned to
study people before I react because
there's no successful person in the
world who's in a good headspace that's
gonna ever attack anyone in that kind of
manner there's always going to be
something wrong with them